If I had Google glass,
I didn't know him already.
Yeah.
If I had that memory link wire thing that Jamie's worried about,
Jamie's going to be the first one to get it and then he's going to like organize
to make sure that no one at my thought on that too.
It's like who is going to be the first one they get it and how you had the side
that I'm,
well for sure like money,
Marcus Brownley and Lou from unbox therapy,
they'll get it first and they'll put it on and then they'll start running the
world that does not have it and they go,
ah,
no one else gets this shot.
But Mark Zuckerberg probably already has it.
You don't want to know.
And I think that right now,
yeah.
Fend his case.
Yeah.
It's um,
it's coming.
Something's coming.
Yeah,
man.
What's it going to be?
Who knows what's going to be,
yeah,
something's coming.
Something's going to be more invasive than what we're experiencing now,
so I can be sure of.
You're going to figure out how to get more and more data.
You know,
Sam Harris has a really interesting podcast.
It's out.
It's either the one that's going on,
right.
Maybe the two weeks ago.
And it was all about,
so I should probably find it.
It was all about um,
privacy,
privacy.
And what's the difference between the way a different tech companies approach
privacy actually makes your respect how apple does it?
Oh yeah,
yeah.
I mean they apparently they do it much more.
Um,
I guess the word would be there more ethical about it was that they're trying
not to give away any,
the trouble with Facebook is what it's called.
I was reading a thing yesterday that,
you know,
you put those a doorbell things on,
like ring,
you know,
the records.
People coming up to me and they said,
you know,
you think it's cool for you and your family,
but the ups guy or all these delivery people are getting their picture taken and
sent to a database every day.
Right?
Like these people are being monitored all the time.
So while it's good for you,
it's not that great for these other people that visit you.
This guy's name is Roger Mcnamee.
That's the,
the trouble of Facebook.
It's episode one 52 it's really,
it's very interesting because what would it goes into is about how tech
companies figured out how to tap into a resource that no one thought of in that
resources.
Your data and how much is that worth?
Well,
it turns out it's worth fucking untold billions.
It's one of the most valuable things cause it you can direct market to people.
You could find out what people are into,
what they're not into.
You get,
you get a lot of people that you can get ahold of.
And we kind of gave our consent to this without understanding it.
Yeah.
And they got in through a loophole and this is how they're able to make,
you know,
ungodly amounts of money
just because we want it to have that cool feature.
So you just say,
yeah,
here's a ticket from me.
I
mean,
thinking about the amount of money,
something like Facebook brings in versus what it is.
Like what is it?
What are you doing?
What are you doing this making all that money.
They're providing people with data,
you know,
and they're also getting people to the,
the,
it's like a,
an ongoing psychological experiment in what makes people engage.
Like what makes people comment more turns out it's anger.
Oh really?
Yeah.
It turns out that what makes people engage the most is things they disagree with
when they started having fights.
So having fights back and forth.
So you,
you get people to get really into these polarizing subject,
right?
And then you,
once they start looking for those subjects and those subjects starts showing up
in their feet.
So there's all sorts of things that they get angry about.
So then they start interacting with these things.
The more you interact,
the more more it shows up in your feed.
And all the while they're profiting on enraging you.
I'm like God,
I mean this is essentially what they do.
She creepy Facebook patent uses image recognition to scan your personal photos
for brands.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
So they just take all your photos and the Dorito bags in the back
applying computer vision algorithms to user uploaded multimedia objects to
detect specific objects within the multimedia object.
And promoting the uploaded multimedia object from a user's news feed to a
sponsored stories area.
That's what the patent was awarded for.
[inaudible] vision content detection for sponsored stories.
Wow,
that's crazy,
man.
Yeah.
You snap a selfie sipping a Unicorn frappe it's Starbucks and then shares that
selfie on Facebook or Instagram.
Facebook's newly patented technology can theoretically scan the photo,
spot the Starbucks cup with the help of an image object recognition algorithm,
and then sell that info to Starbucks.
Alerting the coffee giant of the fact that you like it's product.
Well,
they're already doing a version of that with your search,
with the things you're looking at.
You know when you go through their browser,
they're already doing that.
Well,
they're doing it also with voice.
Your phone is listening to you all the time.
If you have Alexa in your home,
it's listening.
My kids and when we do it all the time,
like if you talking about something and they know all of a sudden you see,
I was performing in Boise and so we were talking about Boise,
Boise,
and then everybody on their Instagram was getting an ad for vacationing and
Boise.
See,
that seems just from a speaking it.
Yeah.
That seems like a really serious thing.
It is.
It seems like a really serious thing that everybody is just like,
oh,
this is happening.
Yeah.
I don't remember signing off on this.
The technology is ahead of our anger or our recognition of it.
Yeah.
We don't understand.
So it's already happened by the time you're upset that it exists,
right?
Yeah.
It's,
it's in full full force right now.
Yeah.
It's really weird.
I mean,
we're just talking about it.
This is just,
we think it's,
you're just in your home.
You were in a private place,
but these phones,
they're just listen,
you know,
we just all have them.
And again,
this is something
that didn't exist 10 years ago,
15 years ago.
These concerns didn't exist.
What would be the concerns 15 years from now?
Like how much more invasive as it's going to get before we even recognize that
it's happening because this is,
this is something,
the,
the listening in on things is something that people didn't think about before it
happened.
Right now.
They know it does.
Well,
the face recognition thing is there's a lot of articles on that and how that we
don't realize what they're trying to think.
Totally makes sense.
Right.
Especially if so many people's phones use face recognition software with the
Samsung phones have it,
you know,
my,
my galaxy note nine has it.
Hi phones have it.
Yeah,
and you're psyched about it.
You're just like,
oh,
that's cool.
I don't have to put in my password anymore.
It's just look at it.
Yeah.
I'm in my app.
They also have one that's an iris scanner on the note.
The note scans your irises.
Oh really?
Wow.
Bro.
It's quick too.
It looks at your eyeballs like,
Yep,
you're you,
she fucked.
You know,
man.
What does that say,
Jamie?
I was trying to find this the first time you brought up,
but I know that there's these masks that exist that are in quotes like
hyperrealistic masks that can be used to,
I don't know if it's this,
it's used to help the facial recognition,
but I think people are using them to trick it and do fake stuff and like,
no,
I don't know if you could commit a robbery with that on and Whoa,
just like having a ski mask on now.
They just can't see your face.
But it'll thinks I'm right.
If you had a Hoodie on.
Yeah.
What about in minority report?
Remember when they had to pull his eye,
they were selling eyeballs on the black market for the eye scan to get into
buildings and stuff to do with that is put like a Bandana around your mouth.
Right?
So it could,
no one could see your mouth moving.
Have that thing on your sunglasses.
Yeah,
but my,
even my iPhone gets through my sunglasses.
I don't know how I know.
So let's facial recognition.
So,
but,
but what I'm saying is with this,
like if you'd wanted to rob someone and have something like even the facial
recognition software would,
would think that it would legitimately think you were somebody else.
Hopefully now.
And what about fully,
if you're wondering doing our crops.
Someone tried to rob somebody and we're trying to rob.
Sorry.
Hopefully not you guys.
Criminals.
That's crazy.
It's kind of happened but it's so fast too.
I mean,
you know,
this is so new wall.
So the like the special effects technology that allows people to make faces
like,
oh look how beautiful those things look like.
So close to a person.
Commodities for 200 bucks.
You can buy one should do it.
Listen,
I'm going to get you cool.
I should buy you and then see if I
yeah bro.
That would be crazy.
It would be cool.
That'd be crazy to see if he can put up your phone.
It looks super creepy but oh that's so weird.
Yeah,
he looks like a demon.
If they could add a little latex there could be moveable Kinda.
Wow.
That looks pretty real though.
I mean,
you know,
a little creepy,
but that looks pretty accurate.
That's crazy.
Act.
I wouldn't look twice on the walking down the street.
Wouldn't even think about now you'd be like,
that guy has a good shave.
It's like beautiful person.
His skin so smooth,
like a baby's bottom.
It was started off,
that's my face.com and it's now been switched to whatever.
This is your mean.